hey how's it going bros my name is bad
welcome to pewdiepie - you know anything
about PewDiePie one it is that it came
from Justin Bieber's womb all I know is
I look [ __ ] fabulous look at that
dress let's play after many months
Pierre duck finally found an exit tank
there it is Wow ah over month productive
I was searching for a way out he got
time to change his extra pair of clothes
yes I look fabulous so Jim Furyk sawsan
spikes in front of him which reminded
him is something he remembered spikes
are bad they kill you if you touched him
they will kill you I know about twice no
thank you Sochi sorry he-hey took a deep
breath and jumped over the spikes like a
princess fabulous
I didn't oh god what the [ __ ] miss
appear duck what the [ __ ] looked up in
some a spiked block follow him it was
then he realized that something bad was
gonna happen
something told him that sooner or later
the block would probably do something
mean to him what if there's something
not evil you're evil where it is [ __ ]
hell this game is gonna slowly kill me
go away ah piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] I can't
even enjoy a game for it like a minute
oh my oh my god what am I supposed to do
no no how am I supposed to do it then
don't kill me please
I'm just an innocent little duckie I
would never hurt Jamie I'm a funny fit
does yeah blah rub oh I get it I get it
kill him not me or that come here you
little [ __ ] come on
it's still kid still it's still having a
lot of fun mine gosh doctor what I'm
just a little ducky why would you try to
hurt me it's your fault that eat that I
[ __ ] got a [ __ ] all right Oh
oh my god [ __ ] off
Oh God all my new feet okay I got it now
[ __ ] got it now
Oh MLG [ __ ] oh ma that's how I roll
that's how I get all the ladies oh six
bananas of yo ass [ __ ] own dos tres
Monta parada del Valle de hey go enjoy
your bananas [ __ ] I open gate now would
you want me to eat a banana with me
before you go just super fast okay you
threw it down there why you know take
the banana you should have taken all
right then no big deal I'll just replay
replay I offer to you the banana with a
man and I end up dying by a demon hey
guess what I'm not gonna eat a [ __ ]
banana with you you [ __ ] [ __ ] no no
he does it anyway okay
mr. gay at least open now oh my god oh
my no the gate is closed the gate is a
closed nine ah this game is not human
what oh my brofist tastes delicious o
get rekt [ __ ] oh oh what is that oh god
please I don't want to replay anything
No
[Laughter]
[Music]
hmm come on beat the shiny Robin okay
this time it just time it just oh okay
all right
CP checkpoint baby Oh first guy fear
skip rings kill you of course why
wouldn't they
those [ __ ] rings man no rings
thank you
yeah I know I play these games enough
now oh my god hey hi there chap alright
just get it good haha [ __ ] is wrong with
you
don't hurt me all right cool wait call
wait Carl ah oh my god I only need to
slide into his vagina hole can I just
walk past him ah what what no no no I
don't want to defeat anyone what the
[ __ ] are those I'm gonna go oh god it's
that [ __ ] black [ __ ] again oh god
it's coming oh my god hurry hurry yes
yes no no coins for me thing Oh God
it's grandpa's he [ __ ] me damn it I
thought I had a new dress yo to the ho
to Jah
that's right grandpa you Inc you ain't
gonna [ __ ] anyone [ __ ] oh my god am i
alive I think I'm alive oh oh it's
helicopter at grandpa coal I am glad to
see you did something with your spare
time I don't like I don't come on mining
oh my god I did it
don't [ __ ] this up man don't [ __ ] this
up heads what the [ __ ] is that I can't
there's too many oh my god oh it looks
like a died oh my god
what a hell right there
there wasn't soft on stage a blah blah
blah hey hey Harry no bye dear it's just
game so much fun having so much fun come
here yes
suck on that grandpa tits and now we
jump over the spikes and we watch out
for whatever the whatever whatever do
whatever it's demon spawn just like you
gonna give this one more try baby
one more try one [ __ ] more mother
[ __ ] [ __ ] ass licking piece of
[ __ ] [ __ ] try alright I got toilet
paper still in my mouth more mushy like
a school ooh talking and handsome
shudder more mostly lucky raucous cooler
talk gang and I don't shot what the [ __ ]
am I supposed to do
[Music]